les passeports que nous vous présentons
ici sont exrit d'un journal à souche de
passeport réservés à des immigrants
chinois ou indiens qui souhaitent entrer
chez eux ou se rendre à Madagascar en
192 et
1925 à la recherche d'une manœuvre
nouvelle pour anticiper la fin de
l'esclavage les colons réignonnis
tournent leur regard vers l'Asie et plus
particulièrement vers la Chine et l'Inde
l'immigration indienne commence vers
1830 dès le début de l'année
1844 les premiers travailleurs chinois
en provenance de Malaisie et de
pouopinang débarquent à la Réunion
de 1844 à
1846 cinq navires se relaent pour amener
à la Réunion quelques 500 engagés
chinois les engagés asiatiques sont
victimes des attaques de la presse et de
l'opinion publique qui réclament leur
expulsion dans les années
1860 la Réunion est en pleine expansion
économique l'île a besoin de main-
d'œuvre et une nouvelle phase migratoire
se met en place
les Chinois viennent de canton pour la
plupart quelquesuns de shanghï et de
Pékin les Arabes quant à eux sont des
Indiens musulmans de gougerat et de la
région de
bomb à la veille de la Première Guerre
mondiale les mentalités évoluent les
créoles reconnaissent que la réussite
des asiatiques est dû pour une grande
part à leur don pour le négo et à leur
ardeur au travail de 1920 à 1930 les
retours vers la Chine se multiplient les
plus jeunes sont renvoyés par leurs
parents qui désirent les y rejoindre
quand leur fortune sera faite les
passeports présentés ici attestent de ce
mouvement
migratoire les passeports sont tous
accompagnés d'une photographie du
déclarant mais aussi parfois de son
épouse et de ses
enfants il renseigne sur l'âge les
caractéristiques physiques les signes
particuliers à profession du
déclarant la souche reste dans le
registre pour l'administration de la
police et le passeport est remis au
déclarant des renseignements sont
identique sur la souche et sur le
passeport ces passeports et d'autres
documents relatifs à l'immigration à la
réunion nous permettent de connaître les
ancêtres d'une partie de la population
réunionnaise il constitue un pan des
archives du
peuplement